let's get one slimy thing straight we  will always be bad guys the five of you  are villains oh stop you're making me  blush why don't you move those pretty  eyes to this exclusive clip instead  [Music]  wolf  what are you doing what yeah  oh that  i'm sorry i thought it was uh obvious  we're gonna go good  uh you totally lost me i told him to  stop drinking out of the toilet hey did  you get hit on the head what no my  cousin got hit on the head with an  anchor and after that he only swam in  the circle no guy guys guys you're not  following me  the bad guys become the good guys  so we can stay in the bad guys  bad guys acting good it's the ultimate  bad guy thing it's fantastic look you're  a genius